ja wir wollen nach new york schauen dort
hat jetzt so wieder geöffnet und dort
lebt auch die weltberühmte tigerdame
nadja sie wurde bekannte weise positiv
auf das corona virus getestet wurde wie
es in tiger damen jetzt geht das weiß
bild reporter herbert bauernebel
dreieinhalb monate war der brand so
geschlossen wegen der korona virus
pandemie jetzt hat einer der
berühmtesten und größten zoos der erde
wieder seine pforten geöffnet 4000 tiere
sind hier zu bewundern 650 verschiedene
arten um natürlich ganz berühmt die
tiger und die löwen und genau diese
raubkatzen haben eben für schlagzeilen
gesorgt zu beginn der caro navi russa
pandemie als bekannt wurde dass ein
tigerweibchen namens nadia positiv
getestet wurde auf das corona virus
weitere drei tiger und drei löwen hätten
einen trockenen husten entwickelt man
hat angenommen dass auch sie am virus
leiden wie ein bild lokalaugenschein
belegen konnte geht es den raubkatzen
wieder gut sie sind putzmunter und
natürlich eine riesige attraktion für
die ersten besucher die hier gekommen
sind übers wochenende und zu
wochenbeginn in den bronze und für new
york ist es natürlich während der
extremen wirtschaftskrise nach der krone
virus pandemie doch ein wenig
abwechslung ein wenig freude dass hier
zumindest diese große attraktion des big
apple wieder die pforten geöffnet hat